gracias y bienvenidos a una nueva
emisión de reporteros comenzamos
cinco años después de la firma del
acuerdo de parís sobre cambio climático
una ola de protestas ha querido empujar
a los estados y empresas a respetar sus
compromisos de limitar el calentamiento
global en europa los movimientos están
floreciendo con toma de acciones
directas no violentas y muy simbólicas
en francia por ejemplo los jóvenes están
dispuestos e incluso a descuidar sus
trabajos para desobedecer el nombre de
la urgencia climática bloqueos de vías y
fábricas retratos de líderes políticos
en cuestión expuestos en las calles nada
les da miedo ni los arrestos ni los
procesos judiciales los movimientos
ecologistas extinción rebelión y acción
no violenta con 21 abogan por la
desobediencia civil para despertar
conciencia y movilizar a la ciudadanía
durante 10 días nuestras reporteras
karina son gurí claire para acá la
acompañaron su movilización aquí la
historia
[Música]
no
estos eslogan acompañan sus acciones
desde hace dos años extinción rebelión
a diario
sí
21 la política del gobierno se está
cayendo a pedazos dos movimientos que
pretenden despertar el planeta para
ellos la hora de las manifestaciones y
las peticiones ha llegado a su fin la
batalla del clima es ahora o nunca
[Música]
en algún lado de parís
no no
la rebelión se organiza
[Música]
31 años coordina el grupo de los
bloqueadores paisajistas de hecho el
objetivo es analizar su muñeca en la
correa en la que le ponemos en estos
electrodos y así nuestro brazo no podrá
ser liberado fácilmente
entonces se trata del sistema desde hace
un año está actuador ha cultiva su fibra
artística en un movimiento ecologista
así como para muchos aquí se trata de su
primera experiencia militante el
objetivo es contar con gente que use su
cuerpo para bloquear pacíficamente eso
es lo eficaz es lo que funciona y es lo
que queremos ver en el medio
creado en londres hace dos años el
colectivo del reloj de arena reivindica
22.000 adeptos en francia'
de 27 años es ingeniero y rebelde desde
hace un año
ingresé durante las manifestaciones
contra las pensiones porque estaba
cansado de la futilidad de la rabia
contra el gobierno también por miedo al
futuro tenía ganas de hacer escalada en
roca y de un movimiento que me
permitiera escalar políticamente para
poder expresar lo que quería decir eso
fue lo máximo somos era lo que quería
ver y a lo que quería unirme antón de 27
años también es uno de los nuevos
miembros dejó a su familia y su proyecto
de casa de campo colectiva en borgoña
durante unos cuantos días de lucha es
cierto que desde que tuve un hijo que
tiene 10 meses desde hace algunos días
ya no se puede actuar asumiendo muchos
riesgos pero cuando lo miro si no lo
hago y las cosas se mantienen así su
vida no tendrá sentido nunca podrá tener
hijos no será posible no hacer nada es
peor
tres días más tarde van a la sorbona a
clases de la mañana
no importa últimos preparativos para
copperhead y su grupo el lugar de la
acción es secreto para no alertar a la
policía
lea les mostrará un plano que ustedes
conocían ayer a dónde van no te dejo ver
para evitar que haya fugas sobre el
lugar al que vamos y lo que haremos
durante la acción
tratamos de diseminar las informaciones
para que todo el mundo no tenga acceso a
ellos al mismo tiempo
los bloqueadores acuden al sitio en
pequeños grupos
[Música]
cuando de repente allá enfrente más allá
del semáforo en rojo o copperhead antón
track y los de más allá pongan eso en
medio tratan de ocupar el cruce de esta
calle el mayor tiempo posible su
objetivo el ministerio de la transición
ecológica
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
también en el piso nos revelamos señor
por qué por el clima y por el planeta el
clima no quiere decir nada
entiendo su furor
pero qué se puede hacer entonces señores
policías únanse a nosotros hacemos esto
por ustedes por sus hijos
desafortunadamente hay que actuar así
hoy en día para hacerse escuchar
julio
pero en cuanto se instalan
cuidado señora que hace señor porque se
agarra a alguien así siéntate le está
torciendo la pierna no la vamos a cargar
vale la pena hacernos esto
vamos señora arriba
como peret y los 150 ocupantes harán
todo para bajarle el ritmo a la
evacuación
no es con nosotros que discutir aquí
sólo estamos para establecer el orden es
todo
tendremos que obligarlos a regresar al
andén
le haremos la fuerza con que irá mejor
con poco más
visualmente será menos agradable
barcelona que españa mos hablando
para soltar los brazos de los militantes
las fuerzas del orden usan más aussi
afiladoras
[Música]
cuando se avecina
[Aplausos]
pregúntale si quiere descender de lo
contrario corto todo de inmediato
cortó la cuerda déjelo caer porque sé
por qué es una negación de democracia
gente que perturba
estoy contento así esté un poco
decepcionado de que se haya terminado
atrás rápido me hubiera gustado que
pudiésemos guardar la bandera y que los
cuervos no hubiesen sido contrarios
como track 8 serán arrestados
[Aplausos]
[Música]
podrán encarcelarnos pero no nos
detendrán harán caer uno pero habrá cien
más que se levantarán nos prohíben
hablar pues actuaremos
no lejos de aquí
[Música]
su política no va en la buena dirección
un otro movimiento
otra puesta en escena
por una misma lucha
son los retratos que descolgamos en
parís el año pasado polling de 37 años
abandonó todo por el planeta como
militante esta antigua farmaceuta
sustrajo estos retratos del presidente
de las alcaldías
el objetivo era reutilizarlos en algunos
lugares para mostrar que la política del
gobierno es un fiasco todas las promesas
realizadas a los franceses se están
desmoronando
un acto simbólico considerado por la
justicia como robo en reunión
su proceso es inminente intervención de
la brigada conferencia de prensa control
de identidad incautación de los retratos
golpe de comunicación exitosa según
polino
tenemos fotos que querían el lanzamiento
de la comunicación para el proceso acaba
de empezar
con sus siete cómplices pretende hacer
de esta audiencia una tribuna política
unas cuantas horas más tarde el
escalador recupera su libertad
frente a la comisaría con sus compañeros
esperan a los otros siete que permanecen
retenidos al interior es muy importante
que nos ayudemos y que estemos juntos
para evitar el agotamiento de los
militantes momentos de depresión
momentos donde nos entregamos demás o
que terminemos deprimidos por la lucha o
todo lo que conlleva es un poco de
psicoterapia interna pero es cierto que
ayuda nos ayudamos mucho entre nosotros
para resistir al final se turnan durante
30 horas lo necesario para que los siete
detenidos sean liberados
el día del proceso ha llegado para los
que descolgaron los retratos tras más de
dos horas de audiencia
la decisión tardará dos meses pollin no
se arrepientan
es el precio a pagar para hacer avanzar
las cosas actuamos juntos y
continuaremos nuestra desobediencia
civil porque así dejamos huella y
hacemos avanzar a la sociedad lo hemos
visto en la historia es lo que funciona
a su lado este climatólogo ex
vicepresidente del grupo
intergubernamental de expertos sobre el
cambio climático ya que rindió
testimonio a su favor en la
interpelación de los jóvenes tiene una
fuerza simbólica muy importante que
completa últimamente las alertas
lanzadas por los científicos con poca
eficacia desde hace decenas de años
la familia de pollin también se desplazó
la activista tendrá que pagar una multa
de 500 euros que quedaría un registro en
sus antecedentes
ello me impedirá ejercer mi oficio de
farmacéutica si quisiera regresar con
unos antecedentes no es posible podría
solicitar que sea borrado pero toma
tiempo y cuesta
90 personas
o link es una de las pocas asalariadas
del movimiento gana 1.500 euros al mes
antes ganaba 3500
cuando sus hijos se orientan hacia la
incertidumbre uno se preocupa cuando se
pasa de tres cuatro o cinco veces el
salario mínimo al mínimo y en parís con
lo que ello conlleva en términos de
nivel de vida no es una decisión trivial
de cualquier forma está más feliz en lo
que hace ahora que así no sea más fácil
para ella y haya más dificultades
es muy guapa
no me veo comprometerme así pero el
apoyo totalmente
[Risas]
como ella 80 personas están en un
proceso en francia total 149 retratos de
emanuel mccone fueron descolgados luego
unos 30 artistas los desviaron a una
subasta
esto está tal vez en su billetera tiene
con que apoyar empieza en cincuenta
euros quien dice más 50 euros señora muy
bien cuánto 300 400 mil euros dos veces
mil euros dos veces mil euros adjudicado
con que recoger cinco mil euros para
pagar los gastos jurídicos de los
militantes y organizar nuevas acciones
tras el fracaso de la ocupación frente
al ministerio es hora de movilizarse de
nuevo los pongo un poco lejos para que
no nos escuchen mucho anthony sus
compañeros deben estar siendo escuchados
yo creo que hay mucha gente que quiere
continuar contenta de testear nuevas
cosas contra la industria de la
construcción en especial el cemento
ramón inventó la producción de cemento
representa cerca del 8 por ciento de las
emisiones mundiales de co2 en su mira
las farc número uno del sector acusado
de polución en escena y haber financiado
el autodenominado grupo estado islámico
para mantener su actividad en siria si
hay gente dispuesta a llamarnos
terroristas creo que hay que ver quién
financia al estado islámico y luego
hablamos sobre quién es el responsable
de 2 millones de muertes a lo largo y
ancho del mundo debido al cambio
climático y a lo que conlleva una
empresa son ecocidios a gran escala son
los primeros en la exterminación de lo
viviente es importante poner los puntos
así es
su plan bloquear los camiones
mezcladores que aprovisionan las obras
con cemento cebo nos dirigimos a planta
en la región de parís
realmente me gusta los conductores
subcontratistas de lafarge se interponen
no
me molesta porque afecta a los
camioneros
solo somos obreros
wow
y que vayan a hablar a la acb es fácil
afectar a los de abajo
[Música]
se complique pasión que es complicado
porque como de costumbre hay oposición
con la gente que trabaja en estos sitios
y citas pero sin nada para nadie tiene
futuro
realmente me buscan me aburro
al cabo de una hora la policía
interviene
no hay denuncia y por lo tanto tampoco
arresto
la empresa parece querer calmar las
cosas envía a los conductores a sus
casas suspende la producción del día
y hace venir a su director de
comunicaciones escuchen no hablamos con
frecuencia nosotros orientamos toda
nuestra producción hacia poco carbono y
menos de 30 a 40 70%
[Música]
entiendo que se ha apresurado entiendo
la alerta
no somos nosotros los apresurados con
tantos científicos de plan estamos
decididos el cemento
su aporte en materia de carbono y
cannabis en perfecto alguna suerte
defendiendo el exterminio de lo viviente
pastel para el tipo tiene rabia porque
perderá dinero
el argumento lo conocemos y estoy seguro
de ello pero cuando se confronta siempre
es un poco violento no contábamos con
suficiente información sobre los
camiones cómo funcionan las cosas con
los subcontratistas a pesar de las
disputas y las dudas durante dos días
los anti cemento bloquearon siete platos
de la región
apoyando sus acciones difundidas en las
redes sociales
y reclutar nuevos miembros para
continuar con su revolución verde
entonces la verdad
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reportero recuerde que puede ver ésta
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
más 24 punto com hasta la próxima semana
[Música]